hi guys silver it again some people
asked me what kind of scenery and stuff
I used in alpha and also some people
asked me to do a tutorial on modern
buildings and stations would do so here
we are and I'm going to do a tutorial on
the station of our farm so first of all
we want to start off with some station
covers especially since the CTR I'm
using at the moment doesn't have any
station covers but if you have some
in-game stations station covers look a
lot better than the in-game ones if you
ask me so I'm going to use SK sr h sh or
lower power something i'll put in the
description it's too hard to remember
it's like a mathematical equation it's
ridiculous and yeah that's that and now
I'm just going to lay the basics full of
paths and I'm going to use a CNS path
way extension pad pavement there's
essentials things and just make floors
with those
and this this station building is just
three squares wide and six squares long
and that's pretty thin for a station
building but I think it does work well
for this one and then we're going to
have some stairs and we need stairs on
both sides because people enter and
leave both sides of the building alright
so now you should have this and now
we're going to open this set which has
some nice floors in it and I use these
for the bottom Moors and I'm going to
take home rule number one and just place
them all over the borders of the
building and then get some columns like
I think yeah you have to use column
number one again just place them in
between all these walls because as you
can see you can create some gaps by
placing these because they're not fully
on the tire so now you take shy guys
Main Street set number three and take
this wall you can also use shy ghosts
Leno's number one because it has the
same texture as this point where like I
prefer to use this one because it's it's
four meters high and shy guys planners
are just one meter high and it takes a
little bit more time to use that set I
always like to add this and to have
different textures of this wall I have a
great lower texture and eight ground
high your texture just to make the
entire building that's boring okay so
now we take shy guys Main Street set
number one and take the cornice in it
which is over here and make it whatever
color you like I like to make it gray
because it's still slightly white but
with a slightly gray H tint just nice
get some corners corners for the cornice
cornice corners it was nice and then we
want to take corners number two which
will be the little details on the side
place them everywhere you put formless
and now we'll take Rafi's beaver homes
2010 and take this little edge piece
make sure it's white or brown something
lights that goes with the rest of the
station and place it on the corners like
this and you also want to place it on
places like these just to make the poor
walnut a bit less boring and one-sided
so now the basic normals are finished
and I'm going to make some simple
station gates and fences using shyguys
planters I always like to use half ones
or the station gates like this on both
sides for this place I know those
vitamin discussions going on about
having station gates on both sides but I
always like to do both sides and then I
always play some fences all right this
station and I also know what my peeps to
go here there is that off and for the
roof we need some supports and we're
going to head over to the sci-fi section
and walls and we're going to open CSF
steel Wimsatt and go to square steel one
beam type - and that's this one and
we're going to place them in this coin
pattern four in a row each time I think
four rows of four I believe yeah
four rows it 4 and then after that we
take the three h1 and we're going to
place three ages on these ones we're
going to open one and
we're going to make this blue
and then place that on top of every beam
it all depends on what color you want to
use for this I always like to use the
roof colo for these connector kind of
pieces and we're going to take these
flat beams I think or the flat beams are
gonna be nothing good of engine yeah go
to beams and we're going to place these
all over the place it's not kind of like
this I think it it's not it all depends
on what you want if you want to take
these one of the other ones and example
I think I feel like I do want to use the
flat ones for the sides here this is a
pretty old set but still very useful
when it comes to stuff like this and
then I'm going to take this flat beam
arc kind of thing and place that on the
sides because these are the things that
are going to support the roof in the end
and then there's a little thing and
alpha that I did as well because I
didn't just do these supports I also
added some of these iron pillars and I
added them in the middle over here make
them just as high as all the other
girders and it's not much but it's a
little thing just a detail again when it
comes to buildings it's all in the
details the more details a building has
generally the better it is of course
shape is still a very important factor
but details can really make a building
even if its shape is really good you can
literally make a square building and
make it look good with enough nice
details and a good color scheme and good
use of different sets using a lot of
different sets is always good when
you're making a building try to be as
creative as you can so now it's time to
place the roofs and for this I always
like to use this set called TNS Spanish
roof tile sets and I always use a full
2h well I always I used 8 to 4 H
roof for the top and a 1h for the bottom
so going to do this top and then get a
1h like this one for the bottom but
we're not done yet we're going to take a
1/8 short upper and connected to the 1h
roof that we have already so that it's a
bit longer than the building itself and
then the annoying stuff adding some
shorts I just do remove like these ones
so now we've got this and all you still
need to do in the roof is add a rich cap
on top bits which makes it look just a
little bit better just like this in the
middle because we're roofs after that as
well and also don't forget the ridge cap
horizontal waters and now we're going to
take our steel beam set again and we're
going to place these steel beams like
this to support the path and then we're
going to open shyguys water wilts at 1
and look for the further in there which
is this one and I always like to make
the footer base grey and put everything
itself sit have the same color as the
support which aren't and well for now
they are great as well so make the
entire great but if you have say blue
supports I would always like to make the
little thing in the middle blue as well
and then we're still going to use the
same set and we're going to take the
support 3 H and we're going to make 4 H
poles everywhere which is going to
support the roof on top of the Q line
because I like to have a little roof on
top of the Q line it just keeps their
guests dry while they're waiting in the
rain for their miserable ride and then
we're going to take mobi steel jungle
number one which is meant for coastal
supports but it's really good for any
structure anyway so we're just going to
use that for this one
and we're going to make a little roof
corner because we're going to place the
roof in it later on but we need
something to pop the roof together which
is going to be this it's a little tricky
thing to get the more right but
basically they have to be well parallel
with the path so the roof can be
parallel with path later on so or look a
lot better now before we do the roof
we're going to open station jim's
fencing and another set - but you're
going to see that later on and we're
going to play some fences so that keeps
on going to mess up and pull down pizza
do next to look bad and now we're going
to take mobis curved walls concrete sets
and add some little walls and you need
the path to make it look like they're
supporting the path because their path
as of now it's looking a little bit too
thin and this one was a little bit
better now these size can always be a
little bit tricky because there you have
a gentle slope but just use the walls
slope of 1/2 1 and then the wolf slope
down have one
and place them like this and you should
be good to go and last but not least
open up and why are single roofs and yes
this will be the last set you'll have to
download and we're just going to make
some simple roofs for the Q line and I
like to make them blue because there
with station of glue as well so it all
benefits over long term looks good they
all use the same colors and silver X
happy so there you have it a modern
looking station building almost
identical to the one used in alpha and
it just uses a different color scheme
but honestly color schemes is one of
those things you could easily must mark
with yourself and it's really fun to go
sometimes and that's the deal that we
just make and that's this is the
original one and as you can see they're
pretty much the same and that was the
tutorial I hope you enjoyed watching it
and you learn something and see you next
time